Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you so much for coming to our mini symposium this
afternoon on the novel molecular mechanisms driving cancer
metastasis. I'd like to first acknowledge
the reviewers who helped us choose which talks are going to be part of this
mini symposium. So all of the reviewers, we had about five or six reviewers,
who contributed and voted on which talks would be selected for the mini symposium.
So to start off, they asked us to do a very brief introduction.
So I wanted to very briefly introduce some of the basic concepts of
metastasis that many of our talks will be focused on.
So as we know, cancer metastasis is a multi-step process,
where these primary solid tumors will have
cells and metastasis-initiating cells that were able to
escape this primary tumor through a process of invasive migration.
And they will enter into the circulation at one point, either through
the lymphatics or the blood circulation.
And then these circulating tumor cells will circle around the circulation
and eventually be able to extravasate out of the
vessel
until they get into a secondary organ, where they can start
to form these micrometastases during the process of
metastatic colonization.
So there's a lot of different components to this process, and we will hear about
different aspects of this process through several of the talks today.
In particular, I want to come back to this invasive migration part,
and the tumor cell interaction with the extracellular matrix is a big
component of this process. We will hear several talks today talking about
the tumor cell interaction with the ECM.
In addition,
during metastasis, tumor cells also have to be able to evade
the immune system and immune detection in order to successfully complete this
process. And we know that metastatic tumors at the end of this
process do have a different interaction with immune
cells in that they are typically a bit more immune suppressed than
primary tumors.
And then lastly, I'll introduce as well this concept of the
plasticity that is involved in metastasis, in that
cells are able to use their plastic nature
to accomplish several of these different steps of the metastatic
process. So we will hear a little bit about this as well, and that
goes for everything from tumor-initiating cancer stem cells, to things like
epithelial-mesenchymal transition.
All of these things that give these cells this plastic nature do
ultimately, we know, help this metastatic process.
So here is our lineup of talks, and we can actually have our first
speaker come on up. And we will go through
these talks, and at the end of this, we will have about five to 10 minutes
left for an open discussion
about the topics that are covered here today and the process of metastasis.
So we'd like to welcome our first speaker up, if they are here. Yeah.
Okay.
Hello, everyone. My name is Alaleh.
I'm a PhD candidate from University of Florida,
Biomedical Sciences, and I'm so happy here,
especially Mr. Jim, my sponsor.
So today I want to talk about senescence cancer cells,
which often known as static
and
secretory cells in the tumor microenvironment.
But here today, I want to
show that they're also actively involved in
metastasis through clustering and immune modulation.
So my disclosure.
In response to different type of cancer therapies like chemotherapy and
irradiation, cells can have different fates.
Bulk of the cells will die, some cells can survive, and there are a
subset of cells that can
permanently stop from proliferating, known as senescence or
therapy-induced senescence. These cells were initially known to be
beneficial to the tumor microenvironment, since they can cease the
proliferation and also through secreting inflammatory
factors known as senescence-associated secretory phenotype,
or SASP, which is including chemokines, cytokines, growth
factors, and this can promote immune surveillance.
But later, scientists also find out that these cells can be involved in
tumorigenesis, metastasis, and relapse through the same
SASP, but over time. So given this opposing
effect, we became interested to look at senescent cells in
cancer. First, we wanted to confirm that therapy can
induce these therapy-induced senescence cells in vivo.
So if you look here, this is the X-gal staining or senescence
staining from immunodeficient NSG mice
tumor tissues bearing human triple negative breast
cancer 231 treated with chemotherapy doxorubicin
from lower doses to higher doses after seven days.
And in blue color, you can see that there is a significant dose-dependent
senescence induction.
Also, when we looked at BALB/c immunocompetent mice bearing
more triple negative breast cancer cell lines, following by
fractionated irradiation after seven days, we could see that there is a robust
senescence induction.
So different cancer therapies could induce senescence in different
cancer types and in different animal
models.Then we establish an in vitro model for our
subsequent experiment. And for that, we treated 231 cells
with doxorubicin from lower doses to higher doses
based on IC50. And then in H&E staining after seven
days, in green color, you can see that there is a dose-dependent senescence
induction, although many cells died at higher
doses. Then we confirmed the senescence induction by looking at
the mRNA levels of beta-galactosidase and
also some of the SASP factors like p16,
p21, and MMP3. And then we observed
that in 39 nanomolar doxorubicin, after seven days, we have
maximal senescence induction and minimal cell death.
So after confirming this condition
by beta-galactosidase probes, we used this condition for our
subsequent experiment.
The first question was how this TERP-induced senescence can affect tumor
progression. So for that, we injected 231 parental
cells and also co-injection of these cells with senescent
cells orthotopically to the NSG mice.
And then we evaluated tumor sizes, and at the end, we looked at lung
metastasis. That was really interesting to see.
In the presence of senescent cells, there is no effect on primary
tumor growth in compare with parental injection.
But then when we looked at the lung metastasis, we could see that
metastatic increased significantly in the co-injection in
compare with parental cells alone.
So this led us to this question, how these TERP-induced senescent cells can
increase metastasis without having any effect on primary tumor growth.
Then we decided to focus on other steps of metastatic
cascade, because we didn't see any effect on primary tumor, by doing
tail vein injection. In this experiment, we used 231
parental cells expressing luciferase and then co-injection of
these cells with unlabeled senescent cells to the NSG mice.
And then we did in vivo imaging.
What we observe, after just three days, we could see that there
is an increase in early dissemination of parental cells into
the lung when we co-injected with senescent cells in compare with
parental. It means that senescent cells can act early in the
metastatic cascade. We wanted to look more
closely to this early dissemination, so we did another set of
tail vein injection. This time, our parental cells expressed
GFV and senescent cells expressed tdTomato.
And then following lung clearing, we did 3D imaging after
72 hours.
3D images shows that in the presence of senescent cells, not only
parental cells could disseminate more into the lung in compare
with parental, but also these disseminated cells were in
larger clusters in compare with parental injection.
Also, in the high-resolution images of this lung, surprisingly,
we could see that senescent cells in white could also
extravasate to the lung tissue, which as I mentioned before, they're known
to be static in the tumor microenvironment.
And also in the presence of these senescent cells, GFV expressed parental
cells could extravasate more efficiently
and in larger clusters in compare with parental
injection alone, which seems dispersed and scatter.
So this led us to investigate underlying mechanism.
And RNA sequencing showed that there is a significant
enrichment of adhesion-related pathways in
senescence in compare with parental cells.
It means that senescent cells may have an increase in their cell-cell
interaction and adhesion capacity.
But to test this adhesion and cell-cell interaction, we performed
adhesion assay. And for that, we added tdTomato expressed
parental cells on top of the attached unlabeled senescent
cells, parental cells, and Matrigel.
And then immediately after wash, we counted remaining cells, and
we found out that parental cells tend to attach more
strongly and in significantly higher numbers to
senescent cells in compare with other groups.
When we looked at this result more closely, we could see that each
senescent cell in gray here could bind
to multiple tumor cells at the same time in red
spontaneously. It means that senescent cells create this hub to
bring cells together.
And consistent with this result, we found out that in the presence of
senescent cells, we could see that there is a significant cluster
formation in compare with parental cells culture alone.
It means that senescent cells increase the cluster formation through
adhesion.
So then we got interested on adhesion molecules.
When we look at the adhesion molecules from our RNA sequencing
result from co-culture in compare with parental, we got
interested on JUP specifically, since it's already known to be
involved in CTC clustering.
JUP or plakoglobin here is one of the key component of
desmosomal protein, which links adhesion to
cytoskeleton.
That was really surprising when we see that when we knock out
JUP, senescent cells significantly lost their adhesion and
cell-cell interaction in compare with wild type senescent cells.
And also in the presence of senescent cells in co-culture with
parental cells, cluster formation significantly
disrupted in compare with wild type co-culture.
Importantly, when we co-injected senesence JUP knockout
cells with parental cells, we could see that early
dissemination of parental cells significantly reduced in
compare with wild type co-injection.
It means that expression of JUP in senescent cells is
required for parental cells dissemination and metastatic
to the lung.But then we asked this question whether immune
system is involved in this phenomenon.
So for that, we established another in vitro model, and
we irradiated 41 from lower doses to higher doses of
irradiation, and we could see that there is a significant dose dependence
in senescence induction, which were confirmed in the mRNA levels of
p21 and interleukin 6. Then we confirmed
this result, and we used this condition for subsequent experiment.
In the co-injection of these cells in NSG immunodeficient mice, we could
see that there is a significant early dissemination of the cells,
but then metastatic growth and enhancement was limited,
same as 231 model. But when we did the same experiment in
BALB/c immunocompetent mice, we could see that not only early
dissemination of the cells increased, but also metastatic
outgrowth over time continued, even more than seven
days. So it means that other than clustering, immune modulation
is also involved in the presence of senescent cells.
So in overall, therapies can induce senescence in subset of cells, and
these cells increase metastatic through two step mechanism.
First, by creating clusters through JUP dependent
adhesion and increase early dissemination of the cells, and then
by promoting metastatic outgrowth through immune modulation.
With that, thank you, and I'm happy to take any question.
We have five minutes for
questions if you'd like to ask.
Hi, I have a quick question. Did you test your
senescent cells to see if they passed the cancer
stem cell test by how many cells can you
inject and form a tumor?
If you
remember the orthotopic injection, we
had another group as a senescence, and it took 30 days to
start just have something really tiny, but it
wasn't even a tumor. It was just like-
How many cells?
2.5 million cells.
Okay. So the-
They're not proliferating
... cancer stem cell is something like 1,000?
They're not proliferating at all.
They're not like stem cells.
Okay. I disagree with you, but ...
Sorry.
Hi.
I was wondering what immune cells you think are playing a role
in the results that you showed on the last slide.
That's a great question. Unfortunately, I can't answer that.
We are working on that now, but if you want, I can
update you about that because we are doing that experiment now.
I have a quick question.
So do you think there's something specific about this mechanism in the lung?
Or have you tested this in other metastatic sites?
So lung is here important because of breast cancer
metastasis, but
the importance of this is after cancer
therapies like radiation, they're locally on the tumor
tissues, on the primary tumor. But some cells can
induce to senescence, and these cells previously known to
be static in the tumor microenvironment, primary tumor.
But in a novel mechanism that we found, we find out that they can
also migrate. And since the morphology of these cells different,
now they can take many
tumor cells at the same time to the
circulation and survive and then go to the secondary tissue.
So it's not lung. Any metastatic tissue organ
can be
involved in this mechanism.
Wonderful.
Great job.
Thank you so much.
And great slides, very nice images, and a really great job.
I just have a curiosity about the clusters.
Mm-hmm.
So when you have the senescent cells and they start to form cluster with the
normal viable cells, do they proliferate more, or do you think it's just
attachment?
Okay, that's a great question.
So in our assay, since they're just 24 hours to 48
hours, I cannot tell you. Maybe
proliferation assay can help with that answer.
But I can say that senescent cells didn't affect
primary tumor growth, so probably it's not that much increase in
proliferation, and it's more like clustering.
But in over time,
I think through assay speed can increase the proliferation.
Okay, great.
But at least in a primary tumor, they didn't have any effect on.
On your RNA data from these cells, do you see any increased
expression of growth factors or any
cytokines?
Of course. Yeah, interleukin 6, really high,
yeah.
Thank you.
Which is the most important marker.
I'm excited. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you so much.
I've got one for you as well. So with the JUP gene that you
identified, have you looked at gain or loss of function, either wet
lab experiments or at the TCGA data to see if there's
an alteration for metastatic progression?
That's a great question. Actually, we were thinking to look at the same
from TCGA that you mentioned, and then from senescence
markers and JU adhesion molecules to see the
relevance. But unfortunately, since it's difficult
to find therapy in the
senescence patients datasets, it's not
really helping. We couldn't find any relevance
there. There were some with coding markers
which were overexpressed in my dataset, but JUP was not
that
dependent. Yeah.
Wonderful. Thank you so much for the great talk.
Sure.
We'd like to welcome our next speaker, Dr.
Zemin Hu from UC San Diego.
Good afternoon, everyone. I really appreciate the opportunity
to present my data in ACR.
My name is Zemin Hu from UC San Diego Lab,
and today my topic is
Extracytoplasmic Regioselective Control of Breast Cancer
Metastasis via TAK1-Mediated
Mechanical Transduction.
So
for our body, all of the body tissue is not uniform
mechanical same. So different tissue have a
different mechanical environment.
Such as in the blood, a neuron, they have a very soft
stiffness, but a bone have a very high stiffness, can reach about 20 to
40 kPa. For normal breast, they have
very soft stiffness, approaching 100, 200
Pa. But when they develop breast cancer, the
stiffness can reach about five to 6 kPa.
It's about 30-fold change.
So during the breast cancer development, the stiffness can measure
by AFM, or we call the
automatic force microscope. Compared with the
adjacent normal tissue, normal place,
the invasive tumor have a significant increase of the stiffness.
And usually, the collagen organization can be
measured by SHG microscope, and is a direct indicator for the
matrix stiffness.
And usually, in organized collagen, it have a high matrix
stiffness. And we also found the more organized
collagen have a low survival rate.
Nowadays, the 3D culture system is broadly used for research in
cell behavior and is very likely in in
vivo environment. So our lab use the
PE hydrogel 3D culture system, and the PE hydrogel can provide a
stiffness from 150 Pa to 5,700
Pa.
Usually, in a cell sitting in a low stiffness, like 150 Pa, they come
from a more organized and round cell-like,
and it's like a normal
mammary gland. And when the stiffness reach about
1,000 Pa, the cell lose the organized culture
and lose polarity, and become
invasive posturing.
And they also have got a EMT-like phenotype.
So what is EMT? EMT is called epithelial-mesenchymal transition.
And for the epithelial cell, they have a tight junction and a hairy
junction, and they have a surface marker such as E-cadherin and
cytokeratin. And when they do the mesenchymal transition,
they go to a more stress fiber and lose the tight
junction and adherens junction, and lose the polarity, and have
a surface marker such as vimentin, fibronectin, and
N-cadherin. During the EMT transcription, the transcription factor
plays a very important role, such as Twist 1, SNAI1 and 2, and
ZEB1 and 2. Our mentor, Jin Yang, have first identified Twist
1 as a EMT, KEMT transcribing factor, and
regulate the metastasis.
Our lab published results have shown that Twist 1 is localized in the
cytoplasm, binding to the ZFP2 to maintain the
epithelial identity in a low stiffness.
But in high stiffness, the Twist 1 is phosphorylated and
dissociated with ZFP2, and translocate to nuclei to induction of
EMT.
Two, so for in search for a
normal
molecule regulating
EMT and cell invasion, we use the basal cell
overlay and hydrogel, matrix gel
overlay system, and treat it with a lot of
kinase inhibitor, including the JAK family
inhibitor, such as
JAK1 and 2, and TCTI inhibitor. We can see this
inhibitor attacking these three protein, they have significant
increase of cell invasion in the low stiffness.
But the inhibitor just attacking JAK1 and 2, they have no
significant phenotype. So these results
potentially tell us that TAK2 can potentially
suppress cell invasion and EMT in the low
regiotis. So TAK2 is belonging to the JAK family, and they can
mediate the cytokine
signaling activity by the type I interferon and interleukin signaling.
And recently, the TAK2 inhibitor, Tucabasertib, have been approved
to become a treating inhibitor for
psoriasis. And recently, a lot of TAK2
inhibitor in the clinical phase II and III
trial for treating autoimmune disease.
To further assessment in the involvement of TAK2
in regulating EMT and cell invasion, we have constructed a TAK2
knockdown in the human MCF10A and the mouse
EPTH4+ cell line, and use them in the
3D culture. We can see that TAK2 knockdown have a significant
increase of cell invasion in the low stiffness in the human and mouse mammary
epithelial cells. We can also use the IF staining and Western
blot to show the TAK2 knockdown have significantly decreased
the epithelial marker, and have a significant increase in mesenchymal marker.
And the TAK2 has a tyrosine kinase.
We want to assess the TAK2 tyrosine activity is
involved in regulating EMT and cell invasion.
So we use our overexpressing and indigenous system to put on
TAK2, and to detect the phosphorylation
of TAK2. We found that the TAK2 phosphorylation significant decrease
upon a stiffness increase.Then we use a TAK1/2
select inhibitor. So this inhibitor is binding to TAK1/2 sort of kinase domain,
and to maintain the auto inhibit
activity of the TAK2. And we also use another inhibitor
JAK1/2, and then this Western blot show this inhibitor
working well. And the results shows that when we treated the TAK2 inhibitor,
there's significant increase of the cell invasion,
and treated with the JAK1/2 inhibitor, there's no significant phenotype.
So these results verified that TAK2 inhibition, not
any other JAK family inhibition can induce
EMT invasion and no resistance. And we also, in
collaboration with Doc Han, in MD Anderson, we got some patient-derived
tumor cells, and we isolate tumor cells from the oglio, and see
that this node oglio in our P3 hydrogen three culture system.
And
we can see in this patient-derived ogliose is in sensitivity,
and in high sensitivity they have significant increase of invasion.
And we treated the two different TAK2 inhibitor.
There are significant increase of cell invasion.
And also, the TAK2 inhibitor have a significant decrease of the cell
epithelial marker, and have a significant increase of the mesenchymal marker after
treated with the TAK2 inhibitor.
And
previously, I have point out Twist1 translocate into the nuclei, and
it's very important for the EMT induction.
So we want to detect the TAK2 have a function to
regulate the Twist1 localization.
So we have constructed TAK2 knockdown, and use a TAK2 inhibitor to detect
a Twist1 localization in a no
stiffness. We can see in a TAK2 knockdown, and the TAK2 inhibition have a
significant increase of the
Twist1 translocate into the nuclei.
To directly verify the
TAK2 knockdown induction
EMT and cell invasion is mediated by Twist1, we construct a
double knockdown, and we found that the Twist1 and the
TAK2 double knockdown has significant blocking the TAK2 knockdown
inducing EMT. And also, I
have then shown that the TAK2 knockdown increased the
mesenchymal marker, and a decrease epithelial marker is broken by the
Twist1 and the TAK2 double knockdown.
And also, the
low ligand independent EPHA2 phosphorylation serine 197 is
responsible for the Twist1 phosphorylation and translocation to the nuclei
to induction EMT. We found that on the TAK2 knockdown have significant
increase of the phosphorylation of the EPHA2 at serine 97 in the
human mammary
SNI, and patient-derived oglios.
And the mechanism is that TAK2 have a high
activity in a low stiffness, and in high
stiffness, the TAK2 activity significantly decrease, and the binding affinity with
the EPHA2 is significantly decreased.
And also, we detect a Nyn activity.
Nyn is responsible to phosphorylation Twist1, and
promote EMT transaction. We found that TAK2 knockdown have a significant increase
of the Nyn activity too.
So how matrix stiffness regulate TAK2, we want to ask.
So we use a microarray tissue and also the normal breast tissue.
We detect the high TAK2 localization
in these tissues. We found that TAK2 have a significant
membrane localization in the non-breast tissue.
In the data codes, it co-localized with the membrane marker E-cadherin.
But in the breast tissue, the TAK2 greatly lose the
membrane localization, and lose the colocalization with the E-cadherin.
And we know the TAK2 can bind into the interferon-1, and
JAK1 can bind into a interferon-alpha 2 can mediate a downstream
signaling. And
we do a lot of knockdown, and only the interferon-alpha 1 knockdown
have a similar phenotype, just like TAK2 knockdown.
Knockdown JAK1 and interferon-alpha 2, and blocking the static learning, they
have no significant phenotype. So it means that
interferon-alpha 1 is important for mediated TAK2 knockdown induce the
EMT.
To finally identifying is interferon-alpha 1 is
important to maintain
TAK2 in the cell membranes. We do a interferon knockdown, and we found the
interferon knockdown have a significant decrease in cell membrane localization
in the low stiffness.
And what is the mechanism? So we do a pull-down and
to detect phosphorylation of the TAK2, we found that
knockdown interferon has significant decrease of the TAK2
phosphorylation. And also in the low stiffness, interferon have high binding
affinity with the TAK2 and also the EPHA2.
But in high stiffness, the TAK2 binding with the interferon is significantly
decreased, also with the EPHA2.
So what's the role of the TAK2 invasion and metastasis in vivo?
So firstly, we have used a breast cancer cell line MCF10D size
GF enabler cell, do an orthotopic injection to the mammary fat pad with the NT
mice, and we found that TAK2 knockdown have no effect of the tumor growth
and the tumor weight. And TAK2 knockdown have a significant increase of
lung dissemination. We can see this quantification.
And also, the TAK2 inhibition have the same results with the TAK2
knockdown. And the
Twist1 nuclear localization is significantly
increased after TAK2 inhibition in the tumor sample.
And also, using a patient-derived xenograft
tumor and enable with the GLP to do assay.
And we use this GF-enabled patient-derived xenograft
model to orthotopic injection to the mammary fat pad,
and
consistent with the similar result in a patient-derived xenograft have a
significant increase of the tumor, have no effect for the
tumor growth and the tumor weight, but a significant increase of the numbers
to the dissemination to the lung. And also, the Twist1 staining is significantly
increased in the nuclei.So to our summary here, so
we found that TYK2 is a normal breast cancer metastasis suppressor regulated
by the ECM stiffness. And also, TYK2 block
at low rigidity can activate
the TWIST1 mechanical transduction pathway to promote EMT and tumor
invasion. At low
ECM rigidities, the TYK2 is localized in the cell
membrane and is active complex by binding with the
INTERFERON-α1. But in high stiffness, the
TYK2 is diffused in the
cell body and promote the activation of the
TWIST1-driven EMT and invasion. So I want to thank
all of the people in the Yang Lab and my mentor, Jinyang, and also Hannah,
she do a lot of job. And also thanks for the support from the
Fighter Source Singularity San Diego fellowship.
Welcome for the questions.
So
I can get you started on questions.
So you looked at TYK2, and you showed that it's
phosphorylated. Is there a phosphatase that acts on it?
And is that phosphatase also regulated by matrix
stiffness?
Oh, these are very good questions.
So the TYK2 actually is reported
dephosphorylated by PTPN1.
Yeah, but we didn't detect if the PTPN1 is
regulated or by the matrix stiffness or not, and this is we can
investigating. Yeah.
Hi. I was wondering if the cells, any of
the populations, if you looked for keratins in them, do they
co-express with the vimentin, or do they lose that as well?
Sorry?
The keratins-
Yeah
... in your breast
cancer cells, when you saw downregulation of the
E-cadherin and upregulation of vimentin-
Yeah
... did they continue to express the keratins or...
So it's a different intermediate filament.
Oh, in fact, we have do some
keratin staining in the PDX models and in
we do the 3D culture use a patient-derived xenograft, the
organoids, and we doing a keratin staining.
And in low stiffness, the organoid have a high
expression of the keratin. But when in a high stiffness,
the keratin is disorganize and have a low expression. Yeah.
Okay. And is this co-expressed with the vimentin
or?
We didn't do a co-staining, but
yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. Nice talk. Here, over here.
Thank you.
Patrick from Genentech. I just have a question regarding
EMT in breast cancer.
Yeah.
Basically, we know that this field has had a lot
of contradiction over the past decades or so.
And what you're showing over here with the TYK2 inhibitor is that you're actually
locking your cells in an EMT state that has a low
E-cadherin and high vimentin and EMT markers,
TWIST1, for example.
You're probably aware of work by Andrew
Ewald and a lot of the people in the field showing that E-cadherin is
required for metastasis of breast cancer.
How do you reconcile your data in light with what has been shown
over the past decades or so with regards to the requirement of
EMT in breast cancer dissemination and metastasis?
And have you really looked at whether those disseminated tumor cells could lead
to overt metastasis over months or so?
Yeah, this a good question. So,
I think for TYK2 knockdown, and they have a
significant decrease of E-cadherin expression.
And
what's
the question?
So the question is, the lab of Andrew Ewald, for example,
has nicely demonstrated that breast cancer requires E-cadherin
for efficient metastasis and growth.
Yeah.
I'm just wondering, in your case, you've nicely shown that
TYK2 inhibitor is inducing low E-cadherin and high EMT.
How do the cells still manage to metastasize in different models?
Yeah, that's a good question. So, on the TYK2 knockdown, and it shows have a
significant decrease of E-cadherin expressing, but
because I think when the cells are
enter to the circulation, they need to
form a dormancy in the target organ, maybe they need a
MET or something. They have need to reexpress the E-cadherin to
have a dormancy
in the target organ. So,
I don't know they had a dynamic recognition or not.
Yeah, we need to investigate.
All right, sounds good. Thank you.
Thank you.
Awesome. Great. Thank you for the talk.
We have our next speaker, Anuja Sath, from Stanford
University. Welcome.
Hi, everyone. I'm happy to share our work on colorectal
cancer that has metastasized to the brain.
So we are motivated to study these patients because they have a very poor
prognosis.
Most therapies don't work for them.
Molecularly, these tumors are very interesting because the vast majority
are going to be microsatellite stable.
This implies that they're not going to respond to something like PD-1
blockade. And so we want to know what is special in
their microenvironment that is helping these cells grow in
such a difficult and distant organ like the
brain.So the TME is complex, it's
heterogeneous, it's got a lot of cell types, including those of the brain
itself, like neurons and astrocytes.
And our focus today is going to be on one such cell type, which are
the macrophages in the TME. Again,
because these are going to be the so-called cold type
of tumors where PD-1 does not really play a role.
They are not hypermutated. So the things we want to study are,
what do these cells look like in terms of their phenotype?
Where are they located, and who do they interact with in this complex
TME? The reason we want to do that is we think by
studying these features, we can get to what these cells
actually do functionally in the intact niche of a patient's
tumor.
So we leverage spatial biology to answer this question.
These lesions are rare. CRC does not normally go to the
brain that easily, so we are relying a lot on archival FFPE
tissue. One assay we use is the 10x
Citosis whole transcriptome workflow, where you get gene expression
data, but you keep your tissue architecture intact.
So an example is shown here. On the left is an H&E.
You zoom in, you see those classic glandular tumor
cells that do not belong in the brain.
And on the right is the unbiased gene expression signature of the
same tumor cells, since we did not destroy that tissue, overlaid
onto that H&E. And so the advantage is being able to spatially
map any kind of gene expression data as sort of
painless laser capture microdissection in silico.
The second assay we use is more targeted and higher resolution,
so that's Xenium.
Again, similar concept, gene expression mapped spatially.
So on top is an example of the paired H&E, where again, you
see this large tissue area.
On the bottom is post-clustering unbiased cell type
identification. There's a lot of colors, but just looking at the red
cells, those are the tumor cells, again, per gene expression.
And you see this nice overlap in all these sneaking glandular
colorectal glands that have metastasized to the brain.
So now that we have this data, we can start asking the questions we are
interested in.
So first we did a standard differential expression analysis in our
populations of interest. In this heat map, we're looking at average gene
expression, where each row is a gene.
And when we look at the fibroblasts, we see that they make a lot of
collagen-related genes. And as we just heard, what
kind of a matrix a tumor lives in is very important to the
stiffness and the physical properties that help the tumor
grow.
The macrophages highly express SPP1, and overall,
they have this
classic SPP1 macrophage profile that we've seen previously,
also in metastatic CRC, but to a very different type of organ,
which is the liver. And on the top there is a picture from a Xenium
data set where the individual transcripts can now be visualized
in black, sitting inside the yellow-colored macrophages,
which are neighboring the purple fibroblasts.
So knowing that they are SPP1 positive, we wanted to know where they
co-localize.
So for this, we conducted a very classic cell neighborhood
analysis. Briefly, we ask what type of
cell is the immediate nearest neighbor of every
other cell? And to find patterns in our data, we perform
different types of clustering. And after all this, we found five
such neighborhoods that are present in every single sample.
Two of these neighborhoods are enriched for macrophages.
One pattern illustrated on top. So the macrophages are going to
be colored in yellow. And you see a mixture of cells
around them. So we have tumor cells shown in red and
always colocalizing with stromal cells, including fibroblasts, parasites,
and endothelium. The second neighborhood is shown on the bottom.
Very similar. Macrophages, a lot of them here in yellow,
mixing with these stromal populations, but this time devoid of the tumor cells
themselves. At the tissue level of the organization,
this is from one example, but they all look pretty similar, where this
super,
almost a pure tumor neighborhood, which is colored in red, is
surrounded by these two types of increasing
amounts of macrophages and stromal cells.
And just to point out here, there are these rare colored
areas in turquoise. Those are going to be the lymphocytes.
And it's obvious by eye, but also statistically across the cohort, that it's
really lymphocyte poor, and it's mainly a macrophage
fibroblast
spatial organization in this niche.
So if things are colocalizing, we want to know if they do
something. And for this, we turn to our whole transcriptome data again.
So on the left is shown a spatially aware type of clustering
where we're used to seeing UMAPs from single-cell data.
In this case, this UMAP accounts not only for gene
expression, but also spatial localization.
So it's going to imply that in one cluster, there is something unique about
gene expression, but also about the resident cells
that are located there. So one such spatial domain,
again, maps to a mixture of stromal cells and macrophages.
And then on the right, when we compare their gene expression against all
other spatial clusters, we see, of course, high expression of
SPP1 and these other macrophage markers.
But together with that, we are seeing the collagen-rich gene
expression, a lot of matrix remodeling genes,
and immunosuppressive molecules, including TGF-beta.
And we also saw enrichment of a TREG signature that colocalizes
with this particular domain.Now,
SPP1, the known function amongst others is
its ligand activity. It's a glycoprotein.
And so we performed an interaction analysis.
One advantage is that in spatial data, you can restrict the radius of your
interaction so that it's a bit more physiological than looking in
dissociated cells. And across our cohort in more than
80% patients, the topmost predicted interaction was this
macrophage-derived SPP1, predicted to interact
using integrin family of receptors as well as
CD44. And this was predicted not only
paracrine in different things in the DME, but
also interestingly in autocrine predictions on the
macrophages themselves. And on the right, our cohort has a
subset of five patients where we also have their paired matched
primary colorectal cancer. And we saw that this interaction was
significantly higher in the brain niche compared to the
paired primary samples.
So to understand a little bit more about what it's doing, we constructed
a tiny in vitro niche, as it were, where we are
co-culturing saline-derived macrophages and fibroblasts together
with a patient-derived tumor spheroid.
This is a reductionist model, but after performing single-cell sequencing, we saw
that the transcription profiles in the individual cells match
our patient data pretty well. So the Spearman
correlation is over point A. The advantage now is
that you can look at its components in isolation.
So we knocked out SPP1 in the macrophages.
And so when we now look at the single-cell results, when we
compare them to the wild type,
it's the same co-culture, and the only difference is in one, there is
macrophage-derived SPP1, and in the other it is absent.
So when we look at macrophages themselves, an example is shown on
the left where there is reduction of this SQLE
gene. It's two different guide RNAs.
Overall, there's about 20 genes that reduce significantly, and they
all are involved in lipid metabolism.
And we know that macrophages with high lipid metabolism are
classically thought as pro-tumor.
And so for us, it was interesting to see that just removing SPP1, the
macrophage phenotype is changing at 48 hours.
There is a much smaller list of things that increase, but it includes
things that are downstream of interferon-stimulated genes, one example
of which is shown here. When we look at its neighbors in
this in vitro culture, which is to the left, an example
in tumor cells, there's a reduction of many
metastasis-related genes, including aggressive
S100 proteins. Here, an example is vimentin itself.
In fibroblasts, we see fewer genes.
Quite a few transcription factors, though, suggesting that maybe this is
an early time point and they're changing or differentiating in some
way.
We next leverage our collaborations with Roger Tsien's bioengineering
group at MIT, where they are able to do these very
nice organ-on-a-chip assays. They seeded macrophages in
one gel channel, tumor cells in another gel channel.
And here you can see the macrophages in
red, tumor cells in yellow, and then by live
cell imaging over time, you can quantify how they move,
how much, and how fast. And this quantification showed us that,
again, when you remove SPP1, there is a reduction in the
speed of the macrophages, which is, again, quite interesting
for us because of this potential autocrine effect on the cells
themselves.
And so to summarize, what we're seeing in this unique niche is that the
macrophages are a dominant population.
They express SPP1 with a potential role in an
autocrine loop that is affecting what
macrophages look like phenotypically and behave like.
They are spatially localizing with tumor cells and fibroblasts
consistently across all patients.
Predicted interactions suggest that they can affect
metastasis-related processes in tumor cells and ECM
remodeling through the stromal cells and fibroblasts.
And overall, we think that they become a rather central
player in how they orchestrate the architecture of
this niche because they are going to be able to affect many
processes, including angiogenesis and immunosuppression.
And I wanted to thank my mentor, Hanli Qi, members of the lab, all our
colleagues and collaborators at Stanford, patients who contributed tissue,
other collaborators.
This is a part of NCI's MetNet.
That's our lab website. Happy to answer questions if you have them later as
well. And we have a version out on bioRxiv, which has
more details. Thank you.
Really great talk.
Have you got a chance to look at the
population of macrophages in big patient data sets and
how it implicates in the clinical prognosis or the expression of
SPP1 in the brain tumor microenvironment?
Yeah.
So one interesting thing is that for CRC, brain is such a
rare site that there is very little data out there.
So there's four and five single-cell profiles from
CRC. However, if you look at brain mets as a whole,
so it's much more common in breast, lung, and melanoma,
there are a lot more papers out there, and we do see
SPP1 in other types of
primary histologies as well.We have far more
data from liver mets because colon very commonly spreads to the
liver. Definitely, they're using similar public
data.
We have seen an association with poorer prognosis.
That is bulk RNA-derived, so we know
macrophage stromal gene expression as a whole is enriched.
This kind of SPP1 collagen, these gene signatures.
TCGA also, it does show up as higher.
It's been well-described also in primary tumors.
It's definitely present in primaries.
Hi, great talk.
I was wondering, so you have a co-expression of your SPP1
with other lipid-associated genes like
GPNMB, APOE.
So with your knockdown, are you seeing that you're knocking
down generally lipid macrophages?
Or are they like an SPP1 specific type of macrophage
and not the lipid macrophages?
Right. So
this is at 48 hours. At that point, we
definitely see APOE itself go down, but the rest of the genes are very
lipid classic cartoon pathway cholesterol/lipid.
So for example, the matrix remodeling
components, we did not see change at that time point.
We saw TREM1 change, not TREM2 in this case.
So there is overlap, but it's not literally every single...
I think you're familiar with them, so the same set of 10 genes that are
always the top 10. Not every single one flips.
Thank you so much.
Hi. Fantastic talk. In addition to macrophages, do you
think neurons are playing role in the metastasis?
And do you think studying them together with
macrophages would be helpful?
Absolutely, yeah. And I think there's a lot of new literature showing that very
elegantly in more physiological module systems.
So what I didn't have a chance to say is where we identified those cell
neighborhoods.
One of those domains, or rather the co-clustering part, that's
way richer in the brain parenchyma.
And we don't have
true adjacent normal brain, but spatially, you can tell a
part that doesn't have tumor versus one that does.
And we do see changes in expression.
Neurons were a little harder to interpret.
Easier were the
oligodendrocyte signals more because you can spot the
myelin programs more easily. There is something with the neurons, but
I'm not 100% sure what exactly is changing.
A lot of pretty generic solute carrier and markers like
those were changing.
Right. So do you think that studying these processes together using
spatial transcriptomics, where you can capture more data at one
time and study the interactions much more better, would
help elude further?
I think so. So even the candidates we have, I think they're a good starting
point to then turn to more functional assays and begin to perturb
that gene less, versus especially for colon, having no data to
begin with, and not knowing what would you want to change in those
brain parenchymal cells.
Right. So I think that's also a use case where you don't
have much data.
Right.
Then you produce the data and then decipher further rather than studying only one
event at a time, right?
Exactly, yeah.
Thank you.
That was an excellent talk, and I just quickly read your paper on BioRxiv
just now, and it was also really great. So congratulations on that.
My question is more of, what do you think the impact of
macrophages presumably in the CSF is to this?
Because I
haven't looked at that. I'm not a brain surgeon, but
are there macrophages in the CSF? And do you think that
CSF-produced and
SPP1 macrophages have a role to play in this as well?
That's a beautiful question. Thanks. So in these patients, I have no idea.
We don't actually have the CSF. I know you do get
immune cells in the CSF in general.
Would be very interesting to study those.
So as a part of the MetNet, so Melanie Geppert, who leads the
Stanford MetNet, has done some nice work in CSF from breast
metastasis to the brain.
Not specifically at macrophages, but there are a lot of signals in the
CSF. And like you said, that's a potentially
accessible, although slightly invasive, but accessible source
of material.
Right.
Yeah, that would be cool to study.
And then my next question is, is there a human SPP1
inhibitor
to choose?
There's a neutralizing antibody
which should reduce its ligand activity.
Right, in the mouse.
Oh.
No.
Supposed to also bind to the human SPP1.
Right. Yeah, but it's not in the clinic, I guess is my question.
No.
Yeah.
Okay. All right. Sounds good. Thank you so much.
Great. Thank you so much, Dr. Singh.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I would like to welcome our next speaker, Dr. Teresa Esposito.
Okay. Thank you for inviting me here today.
I will present the main project of my postdoctoral work,
which is based on the study of EDAR1 in breast cancer brain
metastasis.
So ADAR1, as the name suggests, is an adenosine deaminase
enzyme, which converts adenosines to inosines, which are de
facto read as guanosines. As you can appreciate here,
once inosines are translated, they can lead to transcriptome
remodeling. And this is a physiological mechanism that is really
important to prevent
an inflammatory response upon
activation of the double-stranded RNA.
ADAR1 has been largely implicated in cancer progression,
especially in immune evasion and replicative
immortality.
And this is mainly achieved by
exploiting this function of ADAR1, of modifying all
the double-stranded RNA in normal and
also Z alpha conformation,
so that it will maintain a very
tumor-suppressed microenvironment.
When we looked at ADAR1 in breast cancer cases, it
is interesting to appreciate here that in both
cases there are
both treated and untreated high-grade breast cancer patients that
are associated with reduced survival
whenever there is ADAR1 activation.
And this led to the hypothesis that perhaps ADAR1 is
important
in the maintenance, initiation, and support of the metastatic
microenvironment.
When we talk about brain metastasis, as we just heard a
talk,
we are considering 2% of all the
cancer cases, and breast is one of the most common sites.
It is estimated that between 5% and 15% of women will
develop, at a certain point, brain metastasis, and
they have a specific preference to be formed by
HER2 or triple-negative breast cancer cases.
Interestingly, breast cancer is likely not the main
cause of
disease death, but mainly from
metastatic cases. And because the breast is one of the
most common but also least studied, I decided
to focus on that. To make a model of breast cancer brain
metastasis, we used the triple-negative breast cancer cells
that we implanted via ICB in brain of
immunocompromised mice. And we used an ADAR1 reporter to
trace ADAR1 activity. As you can see, then ADAR1 cells were
sorted and used for single-cell sequencing.
As you can appreciate on the right here, we can see that there is formation of
metastasis in the brain, but also down the spine.
And in a first round of
single-cell analysis, by comparing implanted and non-implanted cells,
what we were able to see is that the implanted cells,
they really form a more invasive cluster.
And one of the top terms in the gene set enrichment
analysis was upregulation of ECM receptor.
Indeed, setting up the stage for
an important mechanism to study for metastatic spreading.
Here then we compared
both implanted and non-implanted cells, triple negative breast cancer cells on
the left. And we could see that there is indeed upregulation of ADAR1 and
specifically the P150 isoform that is stimulated by interferon.
Then we looked at CD47 genes, which
have been shown by Andreas Strumpf and the Jameson
laboratory in the past to be involved in the formation of cancer
stem cells initiating.
And
then we looked at the upregulation of beta-catenin because of the ECM and
also collagen VI that were largely expressed in implanted
cells. And then we compared controlled brain with metastasis,
and we could see indeed that there was really a preference for a
specific subtype of them for beta-catenin and also
collagen type VI. Here a little bit, I wanted to
look more deeply at the different types of
breast cancer that we collected, and you can see that the metastasis,
they
really do have upregulation of ADAR1 P150,
specifically in the triple-negative and ER2 positive cancer cases.
So because of the longstanding interest of the Jameson laboratory
in the study of beta-catenin, I started looking at
beta-catenin in patient samples together with ADAR1.
As you can see here, every time there is a strong nuclear
staining of ADAR1, this also correlated with nuclear
translocation and activation of beta-catenin.
Whereas whenever we saw a dotted appearance, this did not
lead to activation of beta-catenin.
And interestingly, this correlated also with the negative
regulator of beta-catenin, GSK3B,
that when it is phosphorylated on serine 9, like in this case,
it cannot target beta-catenin for proteasomal degradation.
And interestingly, we also correlated this data with
histological data. We could see that the patient that, for example, had the
highest level of ADAR1, beta-catenin, and
also KI67, was also the one that was most poorly
differentiated. And then I stained for collagen type VI.
What is really interesting is that the patient tumors that have higher collagen
VI, they actually have a
metastatic niche that is not really well formed.
There are fewer cells. So this led to the hypothesis that perhaps
collagen deposition may be an early event in the
tumorigenesis in ADAR1 and later
one.Next, we started exploring
ADAR1 expression in metastatic patient
samples.
To this purpose, we collected the six metastases mainly from the breast, but
also from the lung because it is the most common site.
And as you can see, most of them are F2 upregulated.
And we looked at the clusters that had higher level of
ADAR1. In this case, it was one of the patient-specific
samples that had higher expression of ADAR1, and this is
also the one that was the most poorly differentiated.
And it correlated with activation of both PRMT1 and FASN, that have
both been correlated with fatty acid biosynthesis and lipid
remodeling. And we know from the literature that lipid
remodeling is really important for the brain metastasis to allow
cells to adapt to the metastatic niche.
However, when we looked at ADAR1 and PRMT1,
there is always upon loss of ADAR1,
downregulation of PRMT1, but this mechanism ended up being
editing independent. And, yeah. I will
not show it for purpose of time in this case.
So we focused next on ADAR1 dependent
function. In this case, before implanting the cells
in mouse,
I have transduced the cells with
shRNA for ADAR. And what is interesting, you can notice
that both before and after implantation, the level of knockdown
is maintained constant,
meaning that the cells won't directly die, but they would have an effect on
the metastatic niche. So here is the UMAP that we could
see, and
because I have FACS sorted the cells for GFP in this case, we are
not really identifying different cell type, but
rather different cell states.
And cluster one, the invasive cluster, was the one that had the
highest phenotype, the highest in the knockdown,
and I will focus on that in a minute.
I will just
show that the clusters that were more towards on the left
were the ones that were acquiring more neural phenotype.
They had indeed a strong reduction in collagen genes, collagen
VI, but also collagen XVIII and others.
And also,
they showed impaired components of other ECM markers that
these markers are mainly downstream of TGF beta.
So, because ADAR1 is an editing enzyme, we really
wanted to look at specific mechanism related to ADAR1
activity. And we focused on cluster one because it was the cluster that
had the strongest phenotype and also it still maintained
impaired ECM signaling.
So as you can see, there is quite a good knockdown and reduced
editing in the knockdown samples.
And we identified novel targets, among which we focused
on LPP, lipoma preferred partner, because this is
an emerging protein that plays an important role
specifically in metastasis and invasion, and it forms
zinc finger that allows for
protein-to-protein interaction.
And
when we looked at LPP
in the bulk sequencing samples,
again, these are all implanted cells, so in our
mouse model, we see that there is a drastic reduction of
ADAR1 editing in LPP in case of the knockdown.
And as you can see here, we see that most of the
editing happens at introns or around gene
bodies. But even more interestingly, when we looked
at
patient samples and the metastatic patient samples compared to
normal brain, they had indeed increased editing,
gain of editing for LPP.
And so what is really the connection between
ECM remodeling and ADAR1? Well, I just want to bring up this
study that has shown that after prolonged exposure of
cells to TGF beta, there is a noncanonical
pathway that
drives the expression of JunB. And when they looked
specifically at which pathways are important for
prolonged exposure to the TGF beta, we can see that there is increase in
focal adhesion and ECM receptor interaction.
And this was relevant because unpublished data from the Jamieson Laboratory had
indeed found that ADAR1 binds to Jun, but
also JunB. And specifically, we can see both isoform
P110 and P150 forming peaks for Jun and JunB
in eCLIP data.
And so, what is really the connection between ECM and ADAR1
remodeling? Well, we saw that most of the clusters with ADAR1 knockdown,
single-cell sequencing analysis, they did have a downregulation of
both JunB and TGFB1. And then we looked
at Cell Chat analysis
that can identify connections between
different clusters. And if we look at cluster three, for example, that
are the metastasis-associated macrophages, this one seems to send
signals to cancer-associated fibroblasts and endothelial
cells. And TGF beta was really the top
hit forming cellular connections.
And
finally, in triple negative breast cancer for now, I've seen that when you
remove ADAR1, you can see that there is more accumulation of
LPP to the nuclei, and there is less formation of
structures at the end of cellular connection,
meaning that perhaps the protein is not
functional.So in conclusion, ADAR1 that was already
known to be involved in several mechanisms common to
cancer and wound healing, has been now
found to be important for the metastasis and
invasion. And in particular, we define it as a
metastatic switch because via TGF-beta, it can
really support metastatic growth and
progression. And this study adds a new
layer to the non-canonical TGF-beta, whereby we can see that
the all the genes related to invasion and ECM
remodeling, and also Wnt beta-catenin, they are probably
connected by ADAR1 binding.
We still don't know if this is happening mainly in the cytoplasm or in the
nuclei, and this is mediated by
JunB. So in the idea that cancer and
wound healing are a little bit similar
mechanism, we can see that TGF-beta is mainly active
at late stage of inflammatory response to
resolve the inflammation. And so cancer has been defined as
a wound that never heals by Linus Pauling.
And in our case, we can see that even when the cells attempt to heal
it, perhaps they don't do it correctly.
And with this, I would like to thank
people from my lab that are here on second row,
especially Professor Catriona Jamieson, for allowing me to work
on such an amazing project, and Dr.
Thomas Wisenunt for performing the RNA editing analysis.
Then we have the clinician team and all the lab member.
And I would like you to invite you to follow the Jamieson Lab because we have other
posters tomorrow from
Emma, Claire, and Jessica.
Okay.
We have time for one or two questions.
Yeah.
Do we have to do something?
There you go.
Oh, you're good now.
You're good now.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you for waiting. Could you clarify?
I was interested in one of the classes of
tumor-specific cells that you referred to as having reduced
angiogenesis with the knockdown.
Mm.
What exactly does that characterize?
Yeah. We did see
reduced angiogenesis marker.
Yeah. We haven't really looked specifically.
There is knockdown of ADAR1, and ADAR1 has been
associated, for example, also with the editing of LINPD1 that then
led to reduced hypoxia and reduced
angiogenesis. So perhaps it's connected to that.
And P105, you think is showing evidence of reduced hypoxia,
reduced-
We found all marks of reduced hypoxia.
I can go back and look better into it, and we can have a
chat later, maybe.
And it's not to be dogmatic, but the
phrase "a wound that never heals" was first made by Hal
Dvorak, who was the discoverer of VEGF vascular permeability
factor.
Apologies.
No, you don't have to apologize because it's a long history.
But I think in all fairness, as the discoverer
of VEGF, it was called vascular
permeability factor. He came up with that term.
VEGF. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Wonderful. Thank you.
So I'd like to invite our next speaker, Dr. Dave Hoon.
All right. Thank you very much for letting me out to give a
presentation today. So I'm going to talk about a study
of ubiquitin E3 ligase, and this is an ongoing
program, and I'm going to show the next
findings that we made recently that adds to this whole
story.
So those that don't know about this, ubiquitin is quite
important. There's E1, E2, E3, and
especially important for ubiquitination and
then the degradation by 26X protease, which is
important to get rid of proteins in the
cell.
So this is earlier studies we did, and
particularly refer to KPC1, which is RNF
123 E3 ligase ubiquitin. And
we showed it was a tumor suppressor gene in both
melanoma and glioblastoma several years
ago. And what it does is, as shown here, it breaks down
P105 to p50 and it forms doublets where p50 is
a
suppressor and it modifies NF kappa B, which as you know, NF
kappa B regulates many functions, be it
metastasis and other immune. Whereas the other binding factor
is p65, which actually promotes growth.
So these are the early studies that we
made demonstrating KPC1 is a significant tumor suppressor,
especially in melanoma. So in looking at this, we further
looked at KPC1 expression. And what we
found was it related to mesenchymal genes in
metastatic melanoma, and particularly
ZEB1, CDH2, and AXAL, which
are well-known genes, especially for metastasis.
And ZEB1, as those who know the field, EMT is a
major driver of EMT.And
we showed demonstration, as you can see here, we correlated low
KPC1 correlated to higher ZEB1, and these
are tissues from metastatic melanoma.
And we also showed CDH2, which was
higher in
low KPC1, and whereas CDH1, there was no
changes. And then AXAL was slightly higher.
And these are the reset curves demonstrating the
correlations. And MITF, which is in melanoma, went the
other way
opposite, which you expect it to do, and
CDH1. And so this was the start of the study where
we showed how melanoma cells when
they progress become
a mesenchymal type of phenotype.
So we further looked at that, and then we started to do in vitro
cells and looked at
analysis of KPC1
down-regulations through knockouts, and
you can see how it changes ZEB1. And ZEB1 is one of the
key factors in
mesenchymal and EMT activation, and
it was quite significant what we showed. And these are the clusters.
So in melanoma, just to get back to you on this,
melanoma has now three different types of well-known
stages. We call it melanocytic cluster,
then we have the neuroplastic cluster, and the
mesenchymal. We demonstrated this about a couple of years ago
in "Nature Communications," demonstrating through large
databases and other clinical trials for treatment that
these clusters are quite significant as a classification in
melanoma beyond the staging that we always talk about.
And so this mesenchymal is a factor,
and one wonders, okay, mesenchymal is mostly for carcinoma,
but remember, melanoma comes from a neuroectoderm
embryonic development, so it does have that,
an epithelial type
clustering. And then the zinc finger E-box, HOMA box,
ZEB1 is quite important transcription factor, and this is how it separates out
quite nicely. So then we did some more interrogative
analysis of metastatic melanomas, KPC1 diagnosed
to mess progression, as you can see the plots here
in the different-- just in general, the KPC1 of the different clusters.
And you can see it's
slightly less
KPC1 in the mess, and then here in the KPC1
non-mess and mess. But then we separated mel to
N plus, and you can see how ZEB1 significantly
upregulates in mess compared to
the melanocytic or the neuroplastic.
And then the ZEB1 also, as you can see, the non-mess and mess.
So that was quite significant. This is using TCGA
database.
And then we started to do other sorts of studies of progression using
the standard spatial
analysis using monocle C and pseudospatial
trajectories. And you can see here we show the general projection,
but here you can see KPC1, how it drifts.
And then ZEB1, you can see it significantly goes up from
the past, from early stage
melanoma to later. And then in CDH2, which
is N-cadherin, well known in EMT
progression. And however, vimentin is more
carcinoma. There's no changes, although we've shown KPC1 does
activate,
relates, binds to vimentin in carcinomas.
That was published late last year.
But then CDH1, E-cadherin goes the opposite direction.
So this is the switch between CDH1 and CDH2.
And then, so we verified this further by doing proteomic data, and these
are from clinical trials, actually, in large studies where we
got the proteomic data from TIL or anti-PD-1 therapy.
And there was a nice correlation between KPC1 and mess cluster
genes. You can see the inverse correlation and the negative between
these two genes. So this is validated not just from the mRNA but now the
proteomic. And then we started doing multiplex on
metastatic tissues, and this is high KPC1, and you can
see the MART gene is the melanoma gene.
The KPC1 is high in the... where it's high, and the
ZEB1 is not present when it's high.
But then you look at the other side, where ZEB1 turns on in low
KPC1, and then CDH2, which is active in
mesenchymal, lights up. And this is all the antibodies put
together. So it clearly shows how this changes from high
KPC1 to low KPC1 in clinical samples.
And then further we did overall survival, the correlations, and this is the
correlations of here. But here we show it's quite significant.
In high KPC1, you get a much better prognosis
versus low KPC1 and same as ZEB1. Low
ZEB1 is a better prognosis versus high.
So this shows the clinical relevance of high and low
KPC1. And here at the end, we show high KPC1, low Z.
You have a much better prognosis versus the opposite.
So this provides a unique prognostic marker
set for specimens, especially when you are
transitioning from a neuroplastic
type to a mesenchymal aggressive disease.
And then we did further knockdown of enhancing
mess genes, and we show here where we looked at and
knocked down
various KPC1, and you can see how ZEB1 goes
up, and here we also show
whereCDH1 goes down or
CDH2 goes up. So you can start seeing that there are changes
just in vitro.
And then we did further analysis, looking at, again,
experiments of
NF-kappa B changes. You can see the differences.
And then
some changes where they were not present at all were
SP65, which is the activator versus the P50, as
I showed you earlier. And the difference is not there.
But again, the ZEB1
plays a significant factor when NF-kappa B is knocked out.
And then we did the standard cyclohexamide chasing of
protein assays, and you can see how KPC1 goes down and
ZEB1 goes up. So it demonstrates further from a proteomic
aspect.
And then further, we showed knockdown of
mesenchymal reprogramming. Again, we showed the changes
in treated cells, and these are just western blots and showing the
P50 changes from 105 when it's knocked down.
And so it activates what I said earlier about the P50
105 factors.
And these are, we demonstrated through IP that KPC1 actually
directly binds to ZEB1. So it's just not a correlative, it is
actually directly binding to this.
And then further, we did, as well known, TGF beta
activates to mesenchymal cells and
plasticity, and here we showed that when we treated it,
CDH1 goes down and CDH goes up.
And this is just further demonstrating that we can induce this mesenchymal
phenotype, and it shows how it decreases
KPC1 expression. And then we did a
further overall survival of patients.
As you can see, the changes in survival is quite
significant in the presence of
KPC1 and ZEB1 and ZEB2 overall, you can see.
So it acts as a very
significant biomarker per se. And this is our model system where
we looked at the melanoma, where KPC1 degrades ZEB1,
not degradate, but it leads to degradation because it
ubiquinates it. And you don't have the presence, so it doesn't activate.
When KPC1 is low, it basically
doesn't ubiquinate ZEB1, and you get
degradation, and therefore you get no degradation.
So then you get activation of ZEB1, which goes to the
mesenchymal phenotype.
This is basically the summary of the story, but the key
is that we show that KPC1 regulates ZEB1 as an
important mesenchymal, which is an important factor in
melanoma rather than staging the mesenchymal state,
and it's a prognostic factor. But at the same time, ZEB1
and CDH2 is also very indicative of outcomes.
And so it demonstrates KPC1
plays a significant role as a tumor suppressor
in activating the mesenchymal
phenotype. These are the people, as a long-term collaborator with
Aaron Schoenover, who
is famous for his ubiquitin stories.
And then Dr. Nakano was one of the key
papers, and Matthias Busches was one of the
players in these studies, and then the sequencing.
And this is supported by the AMFR Foundation. Thank you.
We have time for one or two questions.
How is KPC typically down-regulated?
Is it promoter hypermethylation, gene loss, or how is it typically
lost?
It's not methylated. We've done that.
The one way we did discover microRNA 155
degrades it.
So it's one of the mechanisms, but there's probably others.
Just like many E3 ligases, it's one of the biggest questions out there
because they do have regulatory. But
definitely microRNA 155
does that. We've shown it both in melanoma and GBMs.
Wonderful.
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Hern.
Yeah.
I'd like to welcome our next speaker, Jan Kadlecky.
Thank you.
Do I do the slides or do you guys?
No, you do.
You do?
How do I advance? Oh, okay. Great. Thank you.
Well, thank you for inviting me to speak about how Jagged1
expression by breast cancer cells promotes metastatic spread.
Jagged's been long established
to promote metastasis of
breast cancer. Eben Kang has published several
papers showing how it provides a competitive advantage in
bone metastasis.
The talk today I'll be focusing on is the advantage
of Jagged signaling to promote lymph node metastasis.
So here's my disclosure slide, nothing to disclose.
Lymph node metastasis
correlates with poor outcomes. That's well established, both by
studies
over the last few decades. So the more
metastases there are or lymph node involvement there is,
the worse outcomes there areThe pathway of lymph node
metastasis involves tumor cells invading into
lymphatic capillaries that typically grow around the primary tumor
and then transit through the collecting ducts of the
lymphatic system and into the lymph node, initially in
the subcapillary sinus. So it has a very specific pattern
of entry and dissemination, colonization, and in
fact, entry into the lymph node can lead to further
dissemination when lymph node colonization
then invades blood vessels that can lead to further
dissemination through the
blood vessel system.
We
created a system in mice to implant
RFP-expressing cancer cells in the mammary fat pad and then
map the movement of those cells through the lymphatic
cell system into the subcapillary
sinus and then colonization of the lymph node.
And on the top panel shown here,
you can see capturing these cells entering
into the lymphatic system at the early stages, and then at the bottom,
just showing a full colonization of the lymph node where
the metastatic cells have grown into the lymph node versus the
tumor-free cells.
Now, this particular project was initiated by Ben Gordon, an
MD-PhD student who's now part of the Yale Surgeon Scientist Training
Program, and he was hypothesizing that
the Jagged Notch 1 pathway may be critical for this lymph
node metastasis spread. I'll show you evidence that, in fact,
we believe there's an implication for the Notch 4
receptor in this particular process.
Some of the key features to remember is that
Notch signaling depends on cell-associated ligands.
So the ligand presented by the breast cancer cell may be
interacting with Notch on other breast cancer cells or on stromal
cells. And the outcome is that
gamma secretase cleaves Notch to release an intracellular
domain that could activate a set of target genes.
This is referred to as canonical Notch signaling and is gamma
secretase-dependent. Other groups have also used
antibodies to identify both gamma secretase-dependent
signaling or non-canonical signaling.
So our starting point was the high clinical significance of
Jagged expression in primary tumors,
which is associated both with poor outcome,
but also a higher propensity of lymph node involvement.
So this analysis was done by analyzing Jagged expression in
primary tumors.
So we hypothesized that tumor-derived Jagged promotes that
lymphovascular invasion and lymph node metastasis.
And before we started, we analyzed both
a commercial TMA and worked with a group in Spain
who had a matched set of primary lymph node samples from similar
patients and had followed these patients for decades for their
outcomes. And here you can see on the top left the expression of
Jagged in this case in a primary tumor, but we
also analyzed Jagged in lymph nodes and
quantified this using imaging methodologies.
So first off, you can see that we replicated the initial studies
that if there's high Jagged, there's more lymph node involvement.
But also we found that the actual tumor cell
Jagged expression was higher on average in the lymph node than
in the primary tumor, implicating those cells
having a competitive advantage to get into the lymph node.
Now, to do the study, we took tumors and implanted them into the
mammary fat pad shown here as RFP
positive tumor,
and then we either injected dyes to follow the
transit into local and distant lymph nodes or
followed the movement of these tumor
cells into local and distant lymph nodes.
And that's schematized here, where we injected either dye
or, and followed the outcome of both the dye and the tumor cells
into inguinal region, local lymph nodes, and to distant lymph
nodes.
To do this study, we created a matched set of cell lines that are Jagged
negative versus Jagged positive using a syngeneic line
CC66CL4, which is lymph
nodotropic. We documented it has low
Jagged, and we expressed high levels of Jagged to have a matched set of cell
lines. We also worked with 231s that are lymph
nodotropic. We created a
Casper knockout lines that
remove Jagged and then re-express Jagged.
So we had a clone that was negative for Jagged and re-express Jagged.
Now, the results we got were similar for both of these lines, but I'm going to just
summarize quickly the 66CL4 lines.
So first off, what we found was that the Jagged-positive
cells exhibited much higher rates of lymphovascular
invasion, and that could be seen by monitoring this
appearance of the tumor cells into the subcapsular space
shown here, and also showing that the dextran first
occupies this space. So entry into the lymph node was
improved by Jagged
overexpression.And, I'm sorry.
Finally,
the lymph node burden itself. So here we are staining lymph
node burden for RFP-positive PanCK2,
PanCK-positive tumor cells. The lymph node
is much more aggressively colonized and full of
cancer cells compared to control cells, and that's following lymph
node metastasis. So Jagged-expressing breast cancer cells
not only invade the lymphatic system more aggressively, but colonize
the lymph node more
robustly. Now, the mechanisms could be very
complicated. So we considered that Jagged may be
signaling to tumor cells to assist in the metastatic process,
or it could be directly interacting with lymphatic endothelial cells to
activate Notch on the lymphatic endothelial cell.
And most of the work I'll describe is at this
level. Now, we haven't defined a precise mechanism, but
what we found is that Jagged induces endothelial
inflammatory pathways and can promote
migration of tumor cells across the lymphatic endothelial
barrier.
But the cancer cells themselves increase activation of Notch,
VEGF, and secreted factors that can secondarily affect this.
So this is just an example of the inflammatory
signature, including
pro-lymphangiogenic factors induced
in the cancer cells that could then impact the lymphatic systems
associated with the cancer.
In addition, we found a novel mechanism that hadn't previously been
described. Jagged being a cell-bound
ligand, not a soluble ligand, we plated lymphatic
endothelial cells on Jagged or control-coated dishes,
and they typically make nice adherent junctions with VE cadherin.
But in the case of Jagged, we could see that it induced this
breakdown of cell-cell adhesions and opening spaces that is
quite significant,
and we use that as a key assay. Another assay we used
was transendothelial migration of cancer cells across
a lymphatic endothelial barrier.
And here you can see that two
clones that are overexpressing Jagged are much more
capable of transiting across the lymphatic endothelial
barrier than control. And this advantage was not present
if the lymphatic endothelial cells are there.
And finally, we used inhibitors that might target
particular
parts of this pathway, notably a VEGF inhibitor that we
created, a soluble FLT, and a Notch inhibitor
that I'll describe in just a moment.
So the VEGF inhibitor
was developed by creating the extracellular domain
attached to Fc. This did not affect primary tumor growth
to a significant extent. I'm sorry I'm missing a slide here,
but it did block lymph node metastasis through mechanisms
that we haven't really defined carefully.
We don't know if this is at the level of tumor lymph angiogenesis.
And secondarily, we've worked closely with Eisai Pharmaceutical, who's
produced the first-in-class antibody against Notch 4.
We published a paper recently documented its
anti-oncogenic activity.
And what we did was we analyzed both the
capacity of Jagged-positive breast cancer cells to get across
lymphatic barriers and to induce this
disassociation of cell adhesion.
Both of these processes were unaffected by gamma secretase, so that
implies that it's not functioning through a canonical signaling
pathway, not likely functioning through Notch 1,
but they could be blocked, both migration and
the cell dissociation could be blocked by this first-in-class Notch 4
signaling pathway. So our working model is currently that
Jagged is activating Notch 4 to induce a
non-canonical pathway in lymphatic endothelial cells that
facilitates entry and transit through the lymphatic system.
And now we'll be testing whether this Notch 4
neutralizing antibody will block lymph node metastasis.
And finally, to conclude, we went back to the tissue microarray that
we had studied for establishing that
there's higher level of lymph node signaling of
expression of Jagged in lymph nodes over primary tumors,
and we carefully assessed Jagged levels in relationship to a variety
of features. Now, this is a relatively limited number of
patient samples, but we
have the ability to monitor patient outcomes carefully.
The one signature we found that showed high level of
significance was increased
relapse of tumors in patients for
Jagged-positive lymph nodes. So if Jagged was
expressed in the cancer cells found in the lymph node,
there was a higher propensity for the tumors to relapse.
In addition, we replicated this work where we see evidence for
more distant metastasis for Jagged expression in lymph nodes.
So unlike the previous papers that used Jagged expression in the primary
tumor, this evaluation was asking, what is Jagged
expression in lymph node-associated cancer cells?
So the clinical significance is high, and we're now
hoping to
do both individual therapeutic interventions with
Notch 4 blockade or in combination with
VEGF R3 blockade to determine if this is an effective way
to potentially block lymph node metastasis.
And I'll thank the critical individuals who
carried out this research. In particular, as I mentioned, Ben Gordon.
We've been supported by NIH, CDMRP, and Eisai
Pharmaceuticals. Thank you very much.
All right, I'll start you off then.
So if you were looking at jagged high and
they're driving lymph node metastasis, does that also
stratify where they might go after the lymph node as
well?
Well, that's an excellent question.
The jagged high cells,
our own work has shown that jagged high also induces higher
levels of lung metastasis. Whether that goes through the
lymph node into the lung, we don't know.
And as I mentioned, Yibin Kang's work shows that if you have a jagged high
breast cancer cell that seeds in the bone marrow, it colonizes
much more effectively. So, I
think monitoring transit through the lymph node to distant sites
is still experimentally challenging.
But I think that could be the case, that because
a relatively high percentage, at least in mouse models, of
distant metastasis can go through the lymph
node, that may be the case. Yeah.
Wonderful talk.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
We'd like to welcome our last speaker for this mini symposium,
Dr. Danmin He.
Thank you. Today I'm delighted to present our
work about lipocalin-2 drives brain
metastatic progression through reciprocal tumor
microenvironment interactions in lung cancer.
This project was done in collaboration with my colleagues from
National Cancer Center, Chinese Academy Medical Sciences, and the Sichuan
Cancer Hospital.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
First, brain metastasis is a major
contributor to mortality in patients with lung cancer.
Its incidence is high, up to 50%,
and despite advances in treatment, the
prognosis of patients with brain metastasis remains very poor.
The brain's microenvironment unique, and it plays a critical
role in brain metastasis, but the specific
mechanisms are not yet fully understood.
Against this background, our study aimed to find
key drivers and review their functional
mechanisms.
First, we combined our RNA seq and
public data search.
We found that four genes are upregulated in brain metastasis,
but
IL2 was the only one expressed in
tumor cells via single-cell RNA seq.
We validated this in clinical paired samples.
IHC staining shows that IL2 protein levels in brain
metastasis is higher than that in matched primary tumors.
Then, we evaluated the IL2
on clinical prevalence. We found that high
IL2 expression is correlated with
shorter IDEFS and which is confirmed in large cohorts.
This high expression of IL2 in both tumor tissues and plasma was
significantly related with worse survival.
This mean confirm that IL2 can be a strong prognostic
biomarker in lung cancer patients.
And then, we decided the function role
of IL2.
In our in vitro assays, we found that IL2
does not impact the ability of tumor cells to cross the
BBB. But when we injected the tumor
cell directly
into the brain, we found that IL2 is critical for
tumor growth.
This confirms that IL2 drives the
post-extravasation growth, not the initial BBB crossing
step.
And about the mechanism of IL2,
starting with the
first mechanisms, autocrine axis.
IL2 binds to SLC22A17
receptor on tumor cells, activate
JAK2/STAT3 pathway.
This triggers VEGF-A
express and release, and then VEGF-A acts on
endothelial cells to drive tumor angiogenesis.
To validate this autocrine axis,
western blotting, ELISA, and IHC staining
reveals that IL2 can
up-regulates
PJAK2, PSTAT3, and VEGF-A.
This reveals that IL2 is a crucial regulator of
VEGF-A driven angiogenesis.
Next, the paracrine axis.
Tumor-derived IL2 also can bind to
SLC22A17 receptor on the
astrocytes,
and then also activate
JAK2/STAT3 and induce CCL2.
CCL2 then recruits macrophage.
The IL2 receptor SLC22A17 is
specifically and highly expressed in neuroglial cells.
This means the effect of IL2 is
brain-specific,
and this effect is not observed in
non-brain tumor models.To validate this
paracrine axis, IF-NC co-IP assays revealed
that IL17RA can bind to
SLC22A17 on astrocytes. And
multiplex IHC staining of brain metastasis tissues from
lung cancer patients confirmed the presence
of activated astrocytes and macrophages in tumors with high
IL17RA expression.
This confirms that the IL17RA mediates astrocytes
activation and macrophage recruitment in lung cancer brain
metastasis.
Also, we uncovered positive feedback loops.
Macrophage-derived IL1B.
IL1B binds to IL1 receptor to activate
NF-kappa B in tumor cells. This can amplify the
IL17RA expression.
This forms a positive feedback loop of tumor cells
to astrocytes, to macrophages, and also to
tumor cells, which continuously amplifies IL17RA
expression and its metastatic effect.
To validate this
feedback loop, single-cell RNA seq and ELISA revealed
that IL1B was predominantly expressed by
macrophages. And macrophage co-culture with
tumor cells,
we can see that the IL17RA up-regulates, and this
effect can be blocked by IL1 receptor inhibitor,
anacaria.
Building our mechanistic findings, we want to
test the
target IL17RA axis for therapy in
preclinical models.
First, targeting the autocrine axis.
Block the STAT3 and
anti-VEGF-A can suppress tumor growth and
extended survival in preclinical models.
And
talking about paracrine axis,
block STAT3 can suppress tumor growth, but when
we combine with IL1R
inhibitor and anacaria, can work best
to
reduce the tumor growth, which means it can block
the feedback loop.
And also importantly, we found the timing matters.
Early block of IL1B signaling suppresses brain
metastasis formation, but when we gave the
anacaria
after the brain metastasis is established, we found it
failed to inhibit tumor growth.
This means that the IL1B IL17RA feedback loop is
critical for the early establishment of the brain
metastatic microenvironment, and early
block is key for the therapy.
In summary,
we found a
diagram of here.
Tumor-derived IL17RA can, via
autocrine axis to
drive tumor angiogenesis,
via paracrine axis, can activate
astrocytes and recruit macrophages.
And also, macrophages can derive the IL1B
to amplify the IL17RA expression.
To conclude, our findings propose IL17RA as a
prognostic biomarker and a therapeutic target for lung cancer brain
metastasis. IL17RA can remodel the brain's
specific metastatic microenvironment through two
pathways, autocrine and paracrine signaling.
And also,
macrophage-mediated IL1B positive feedback loop
is a critical mechanism for sustaining and amplifying the
effect of IL17RA. Clinical significance that
IL17RA can serve as a potential biomarker for predicting
prognosis and selecting patients sensitive to STAT3
inhibitors. And also,
targeting the IL17RA-mediated signaling axis provides a novel
combination of therapy strategies for brain metastasis.
And about the challenges and perspectives, future research needs to
develop novel targeted agents that can effectively
penetrate the blood-brain barrier.
And the therapeutic strategy proposed in this study requires
further validation in prospective clinical trials.
Thanks for your listening. I'm happy to take questions.
So I've got a quick question about your model system.
So when you were looking at your brain metastasis in your
mouse model work, was that an intracranial injection or were you putting
that into the lungs? Essentially, I'm asking, is this a
colonization effect that you're seeing with the tumor microenvironment, or is it
the ability to move through the bloodstream,
to get to the brain and then grow there?
Thanks for question.
We
established the two,
three
animal models from the cardiac interject, and
we also injected intracranially to the
brain. And we found that when we
inject the tumor cells from the cardiac or the artery,
that the tumor growth is not significant.
But when we inject tumor cells directly into the intracranially, we
found that high IL17RA
with the more tumor growth. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. So, for those that have stayed and not run to another talk, we've got 10
minutes left if we'd like to start a discussion.
I think I'd just preface that with saying it was a wonderful selection
of talks. It was a pleasure listening to all of you.
And it really struck me how we really have to look at this
in a sum of all the talks together. So we've
got talks that we've heard on adhesion, and
we've heard talks about the stiffness, and these are
things that are going together for how we're invading the bloodstream or
the lymphatic vasculature. And then we started talking about
the remodeling of the immune component as well.
These are all things that we can't look at just singly.
They all interact and function together.
So now's your chance. If you've got a comment and a question,
this is your chance for a comment as well.
So we'll just open it up at this point, and if not,
we can just move on to the next set of talks.
So we'll open it up here for anything.
Yeah, I couldn't agree with you more because the holistic
view is really where we all want to go to and be able to analyze
all these different processes and understand how they relate to
each other. I'll just make a comment because
AACR had a recent meeting that was referred to as tumor
micro and macro environment. But I'd like to
posit that a better name for that might be tumor physiology,
because physiology is the study of cellular,
organismal, and body system-wide
regulation. And classically, it's the
space where you really understand.
So the tumor has its own physiology.
We study that quite extensively, the pathways that drive growth,
differentiation, spread, but the tumor is responding
to physiological systems, and in turn, the
physiological systems are responding back.
So, a tumor arriving in a lung is experiencing a different
physiology than a tumor arriving in a lymph node.
So I like the idea of not being penned in
with tumor micro and macro, because to me,
what does that mean? That just means everything.
So we might as well just call it tumor physiology.
So I'll put that up for discussion if you guys had any thoughts about that.
Well, being in a physiology department, I don't think you'll get any argument from
me.
Okay. Yeah. Well, I'm a chair of a department of physiology so that's
part of my pitch for that.
No, I think that's a really good point, and especially when we start to consider
how organ-specific metastasis starts to arise.
The physiology that that tumor cell might experience in its host
location may be influencing how it's adapted to
go to different other sites. And then how does it use the specific
transcriptional pathways, or how can it seed its
microenvironment, if we are going to call it that?
Yeah.
How can it seed and influence that environment to allow it to grow there is
something that likely arises from its origin as well.
Yeah.
But no, it is all physiology.
Yeah. And the other thing I'd like to mention is that,
as a vascular biologist,
we're uncovering major changes in vascular gene expression at
a distance from the primary tumor that's affecting the
inflammatory response. And in the classical
figures of
tumor metastasis, like at your opening comments, you showed
the cancer versus the metastatic cancer.
All of the cells had changes in colors except for the vascular
cells, and I would propose that we should modify
that. That figure should include a change to the
vasculature. So for instance, we've seen that primary tumors very
rapidly upregulate an inflammatory signaling
molecule, ACKR1, at distant venules within
days, and that sets the seed for neutrophil
intravasation there. So that's a change to an
endothelium in the pre-metastatic niche.
So those are my two comments.
No, I completely agree with you. Yeah, the
biology of that metastatic tumor niche is very different from the primary tumor.
So it is not specific only to those tumor cells or the immune cells.
I completely agree with you.
Any other burning questions for our speakers?
If not, most of the speakers are still here.
You can grab them if you wanted just a one-on-one conversation, but thank you all
for coming.
Yeah. What a wonderful session. Thank you.